probably one of the most shocking
stories i've seen in a long time i
couldn't believe it when i saw this
video trudeau announced his national
plan to freeze importing buying or
selling handguns
now what really freaked me out about
this
is the way that he actually reads it let
me see if i i'm gonna play this video
for you guys
we're introducing legislation to
implement
return
freeze
on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy sell
transfer or import
handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
i i think that's enough i don't want to
listen anymore that man yeah really but
the the the whispery
feathery way he's talk we're capping
handgun market he sounds like a bond
villain this is really creepy stuff
seeing all these people post online
about banning guns outright then they
come out and say nobody's trying to ban
your guns they're literally trying to
ban your guns and i think the important
context here is that uh i think we've
seen from history what happens every
single time guns get banned
well i don't understand yes what one has
to do with the other i'm certainly
interested in irrational discussion
about what needs to be done after these
tragedies i think a lot of people are
but to jump ahead to something like what
does this have to do with canada and
banning guns what does the tragedy in
texas have to do with that well i don't
think it does i think we're just seeing
the the the uh
the scale at which
this ideology wants to go so in the
united states there they know they can't
come out and say ban all the guns
because
nobody wants that inc
in the united states they know they
can't say that in canada
they can just do it i mean do they want
it in canada is that is different there
i can't speak for canadians he got a lot
of applause
he introduced the bill so it was a bill
so we'll see what happens with the
lawmakers but uh
yeah i mean it's it's just bizarre i
mean it's but it's still nothing new
under the sun i mean we've seen this
from other regimes and it is
fascism when the government wants to
take control of the firearms and take
them away from the people and what i
find hypocritical is is people who were
cheering you know the ukrainians all
arming themselves and just saying this
is a great thing uh you know
good for them for arming themselves you
know the hypocrisy they're posting
videos of child soldiers in ukraine
praising them and i'm just like man this
got dark real quick wow
i mean isn't ukraine the exact reason
why some people here say
we should not be disarmed the very thing
that's happening to the ukrainians it
could be argued which is
they taught
right before the invasion of russia they
were actually training the local
citizens and how to use
you know their weapons in combat that
they already had it almost makes the
case for the opposite of what they're
arguing now yeah exactly well and not
just ukraine the rioting that happened
for months on end in this country that
was praised by the left wing
they sit there and tell us that rioting
is an acceptable response when
politics doesn't go their way basically
and then they turn around and tell you
what a couple weeks to months later oh
you have no reason to own a firearm
there was a
during the george floyd riots there's a
guy in new york who called 9-1-1
because people were breaking into his
apartment building and fighting
and he said i need help
the dispatcher said sir let me send you
a therapist they said the city is under
attack what would you have us do yeah
good luck
i mean these people vote for this stuff
or they ignore they let it happen
and then when danger comes in again you
ain't got no one to count on so we we
saw here's the fascinating thing about
all of the gun control stuff is that
there are people currently arguing for
gun control when we just saw the police
in the uvalde incident not go in
but used their authority to stop the
parents from going in who were armed
which is what gun control is by the way
allowing the criminals to have guns but
preventing people who want to protect
themselves and their families from
having guns
and so
another take i saw from
a number of lefties was this proves that
the ar-15 is too dangerous because he
had one until the police were too afraid
to stop him firstly many of those
officers had ars but secondly if the
ar-15 is is too dangerous and terrifying
for a police officer to go up against
who's going to confiscate them how are
you going to ban them that's a great
question
well that's the problem again with the
canadian proposal you're taking care of
something that's not happened yet you're
not taking care of the stuff that
they're complaining about now which is
the current ownership of guns there
can't be anything about that you know
what though like watching uh these
people the these liberals try and ban
guns because i always say is like the
leftists want guns karl marx said to
keep guns the leftists typically want
them the funny thing about it is that
they're so ignorant of guns gun policy
gun mechanics that they're actually
losing now they they win some things
like maryland has banned the m1a and
it's like for what reason what does that
accomplish it's it's ridiculous
but
36 states have permits open carry 25
states have constitutional carry
florida is soon to be the 26th state
with constitutional carry so while the
liberals are screaming banning assault
weapons they can't define what assault
weapon is so nothing happens
and then on the right
they're enacting constitutional carry at
the state level and so now you have 36
states
permit less open carry i mean that's
kind of crazy we we used to if you look
in the 80s
uh there was no concealed carry now
almost every single state has has to
allow concealed carry and 25 are
constitutional meaning you can just if
you live in the state you don't need a
permit at all you can conceal if you
want so they're losing
and and no matter how many times we
scream that you're ignorant of the laws
they don't pay attention so let them let
them ban the ridiculous nonsense and
lose so here's what's uh sick about it
also when you're talking about the soros
funded prosecutors who are going and
picking and choosing which laws they
want to enforce so you know in in los
angeles or new york or
st louis you could theoretically have uh
you know one of their prosecutors choose
to to enforce these gun laws um but then
let you know rapist walk free because we
need restorative justice and that's
that's disgusting throwing the book at
things that uh you know whatever
political marxist agenda you have
and then let's talk about what really
happens behind the scenes because i'm
really big on the notion that i've had
so many democrats and republicans
confess that what they do on capitol
hill they often agree on behind the
scenes but just not in front of
everybody and when i broke the fast and
furious scandal about the government in
essence gun running drug guns to mexico
illegally went before they admitted they
were doing that
initially at cbs it was a democrat
leader of a committee
on the senate side that contacted me
that wanted to follow up on that story
as sometimes they do and they sense
there's a big story coming
and republicans also called me and i
shared public information that i had on
the story happy to make the story get
get more information they can issue
subpoenas and interview people that i
can't get on camera
but the democrats quickly bowed out and
it was clear it confused me at the time
but in retrospect a decision had been
made and a staffer actually told me a
democrat staffer in the senate that this
was not a good issue for them because
they couldn't figure out how it played
with the gun control crowd and the gun
control issue and that they had a lot of
constituents that support guns and they
and i said aren't some issues just this
to me wasn't a gun control issue this
was the government corruption and all
kinds of stuff i said aren't some issues
bigger than that debate but it was also
covering for obama too that was part of
it too well but the status the staffer's
answer was
you'd like to think so when i said
aren't some issues bigger than that well
so so break down the fast and furious
scandal for those that aren't familiar
well this was the government got caught
through a whistleblower with atf i think
it was unprecedented that a sitting
federal agent came forward and spoke to
me on camera about it
they had been knowingly selling drug
guns putting them in the hands of the
mexican drug cartels and it was
misreported and is still frequently
misreported today
that there was sort of a sting operation
that they were trying to track the guns
to the bad cartel guys and lost track of
them they didn't attempt to track most
the guns that was the problem and they
were in essence arming the sinaloa
cartel down in mexico which isn't really
a stretch the imagination looking back
that we often take sides when there are
warring factions in countries and we
were choosing the sinaloa cartel
apparently over the zeta cartel which
were affiliated with terrorists and we
perceived as worse but regardless the
government
was using this issue of guns showing up
in mexico
not telling anybody we were moving them
there and saying look we need gun
control here in the united states
because we're selling guns and they're
ending up in mexico knowing all along
that they were putting them there this
was obama yeah under obama
and you know a lot those guns killed a
lot of people including a border patrol
agent that's why an agent stepped
forward because he had said and some of
the gun shops that knew this was
happening that atf was allowing it to
happen were saying
this is going to come back and shoot a
federal agent someone's going to get
killed with one of these guns and quite
a few people got killed with those guns
so to recap they would rather
arm mexican cartels who will kill us uh
atf uh agents while take away the guns
of law-abiding americans they'd rather
arm the taliban yeah yeah they'd rather
uh
yeah exactly i mean our government has
this very interesting habit of funding
and arming groups that end up killing
americans
sus
how did you find out it was a
whistleblower who came forward this to
this day i don't know who tipped me off
i got a
one paragraph tip in the mail a letter
that said
senator grassley is looking into this
and it briefly describes something that
sounded plausible but so many of my
stories start out that way and i called
senator grassley's office i knew he had
a whistleblower
and grassley's office at the time would
not cooperate with me for various
reasons and i identified the
whistleblower his his girlfriend at the
time
called me because i did sort of a
generic story with what i knew because
that will stir the pot and bring out
other sources sometimes
she called me out of the blue and and i
wrote down the number it came in on at
cbs and she said my boyfriend is
a source on this and he may want to talk
to you but not today
and he never called back she said he
might call the next day or two and i'd
written down the number and i called
back two days later when i really needed
that next story and knew there was
something serious going on
and i said i think i know who he is and
i had done enough poking around of who
the teams were that were working on
these issues in arizona and so on
and um he got on the phone with me and i
said i know you're probably john dodson
and he said whoa you know and it was and
it took a lot of doing to convince him
to go on camera as a sitting federal
agent he's been made to pay ever since
now they didn't fire him because
members of congress stepped in
primarily grassley's office every time
he got threatened
but he's been held out as a dog when he
should be the hero that everybody
emulates to blow the whistle when bad
stuff and murder
you know may be happening as a result of
things the government has done but
instead they've been he's been treated
just horribly and that's that's the
lesson that was sent out to other
federal agents that might blow the
whistle a good journalist should be a
conspiracy theorist to a certain degree
you have to be because you learn
that mo for me anyway most of what i
hear will not turn out to be true
and i try to disprove it on its face so
when i hear that the fast and furious
tips i start going about trying to
disprove the story and when i can't then
i start seeing if i can prove it so
you know but you do have to believe
my my funny story is my husband's former
law enforcement he's a lawyer and i
would come home and tell him about a tip
i got or a story i'm working on over the
years and he would always go
that's just crazy that can't be true and
he said that about fast and furious and
i said
you know we always say that and then
sometimes they are you know well what i
think is also very upsetting is the
weapons flowing from the other direction
so a lot of the illegal firearms coming
up from mexico but because the left
doesn't want to shut down our border
those are coming and circulating in our
inner cities especially you know for for
you know white liberals who say they
care about our inner cities and you know
violence for black americans and and
predominantly minority neighborhoods but
it's like but they will not close down
the border you know and to me that's
that's white supremacy right you don't
care about black lives
when black lives are being killed by
illegal firearms from mexico where where
are the protests i never hear about this
i don't think it's it's it's should be
shocking to anybody the people who
advocate for slowing population growth
are
in favor of things that inhibit
population growth they're in favor of
children being sterilized they're in
favor of abortion and they're in favor
of destroying economies which stagnate
growth
well as you know again as a journalist
you like to poo poo stuff and me in the
early part of my career in particular
and then so many things turn out to be
true and i think of the
some someone's something somebody
tweeted not long ago that became my
favorite tweet which said i have to find
some new conspiracy theories because all
my old ones came true
that's a good one yeah no it's
repeatedly happened with respect to i
mean many things surrounding covet 19
the lab leak hypothesis is one i bring
up pretty frequently but it's also
insane that it was so straightforward
and clear as an explanation that it
leaked from a laboratory because the
disease was first discovered
near that laboratory near a virology
institute they're like no it came from a
bat and you're actually thousand miles
away a thousand miles away and you're
the crazy one if you don't believe that
gaslighting here's what trudeau said he
said
other than using firearms for sport
shooting and for hunting there is no
reason anyone in canada should need guns
in their everyday lives well
that's amazing what's the canadian
constitution say about guns if anything
i don't think it does not enough yeah
probably nothing
but you know
canada
man you know that's they vote for it
i think i think we're we're lucky in a
lot of ways that canada is doing what
they're doing so that we can see we get
to watch all the stuff that's going on
in that country well i'm just excited to
see what the truckers are going to do
next
i don't know is it
we'll see if this even makes it through
because it is just a bill but well i
thought also i thought his country was
just taken over by a bunch of like
supposedly fascist truckers who were
like honking their horns in the name of
white supremacy or something and he's
like there's no reason anyone would need
to protect themselves in this country
yeah exactly it's great both of those
things don't fit together yeah no
obviously it's because he knows that the
truckers were not actually dangerous
with respect to like the physical health
and safety of his citizens the way they
wanted to make it sound they were just
dangerous to the social order he was
seeking justice
owning a firearm thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you